[Music]
hi
everyone it's me talia um
today i'm baking i don't i feel like
this is not my usual
setting you usually see me play and
now i'm baking and
that's how it is so i'm gonna be making
what's supposed to be like a chest cake
so like when you cut it
kind of opens up and it looks like a
chessboard
i tried it at home it went okay i can't
promise
it went like that great also i feel like
i should make a disclaimer that i'm not
like a professional baker
i bake sometimes i made ice cream once
it looks like
more or less how it goes i've done like
two toddler
birthday cakes but like that's about it
so
[Laughter]
i feel like that's as much as i can i
can claim
right but this is all uh
part of the new exhibition that they
have with the world chess hall of fame
called check fleece uh chess dining and
decor
so um i guess you can feel free to check
it out
and yeah so that's kind of what we're
doing today
is anyone excited uh i am
same amount so scared and excited
but i think it's gonna be good so and
hi everyone who's in the chat already uh
i believe this is both
um i believe this is both
uh youtube and twitch so it's it's
you know a lot of messages and a lot of
people and i appreciate all of you for
being here
and shall we get started
i'm gonna um tie my hair up because you
don't
want to really get in the way of cooking
and you're probably going to see my
double chin as i do this but that's fine
that's how it is sometimes
and in the meanwhile can anyone tell me
the first step of baking
please anyone has any clue
what it could be i think i touched
something here now
it says something in the microwave i
don't know what it is but
we'll find out later if this go if this
whole
kitchen is set on fire then
oops right so
no you don't check ingredients you wash
your hands that's the first thing that
you do
i did that earlier i was watching i was
watching some stuff and then i did that
earlier
develop for the eggs no that's very far
away from it
[Laughter]
no uh you just wash your hands okay um
also we preheat the oven or at least i
think we did from what i have been told
this oven hasn't been used in a long
time
so that's just how it is sometimes
um yeah there are some people here with
me just to make sure that i'm dying of
fire
so yeah that's just how it's gonna be
now and um
i guess we should probably go ahead and
get started as long as i don't break
anything
and like i said we're going to be making
one chocolate cake and one vanilla cake
and then we're going to like
layer them in a sophisticated engineered
way
that you know makes it look like a chess
board right so it's going to be
it's going to be just perfect i don't
know what i should grab i guess i should
already kind of start prepping what i
need to add here
and then we're going to mix both of them
in the mixer put them in some pans
bake them and i guess through that time
i can be playing like some blitz and
stuff
okay so yeah don't forget
eventually to like um do some challenges
on leeches
i believe there's a command for that
that you guys can use so
yeah all right so i'm gonna kind of go
ahead and get started with the
with the ingredients of this thing wait
they were supposed to be here
now they're not it's fine it's all fine
all right so let's start with water my
own frame i don't know if i am
okay let's start with water i never use
these fancy things usually i just use
like a glass at home but it's fine we're
going to use this one
and we're going to use tap water because
it's really good for you
is it i don't think it is really
i didn't know that okay fine that's
great
um i also uh i'm not sure if there's
like a specific way that you're supposed
to
to mix it but i just the thing is that i
bake at home
and i have this logic i have like this
i wouldn't call it like a scientific
discovery but i have like this
theory right then
it's fine as long as you do generally
good and if you see that something is
going wrong then you go and fix it
right so i think that things should go
relatively fine now we're going to use
my
favorite thing which is x and i am lying
if you don't know me already you
probably
know that i don't like them
but oh i probably shouldn't have break
oh
maybe i shouldn't have broken it
because this is a surface that i need to
use um
yeah it was a bad idea
anyways no one cares about that um
how are you guys doing today oh wait why
do i dislike
eggs i don't know i just never got into
them i think it's because
i copied my mom a lot and then she never
liked eggs
right so i never did same thing with
fish she
never liked fish and i don't like fish
either
so that's how it is i'm picky with
certain foods and
eggs and fish i would say are two of
those that i just
really hate but of course you know this
doesn't taste like eggs this is
cake so i don't really care about that
okay now i gotta throw this away
and wash my hands always wash your hands
if you're dealing with this raw stuff
oh thank you thank you i don't need to
move too far away
perfect
i don't want to waste like paper towels
but i feel like i'll have to
anyways
um
i have more fun while cooking than
playing chess
it could be it could be true i mean
cooking well of course i love chess like
that's
that's my big passion it's what i love
to do professionally and as a hobby
like if you ask my mom what do i do
other than chess probably she'll like
stay quiet for like five seconds and try
to come up with something
with like some lie or whatever
[Music]
but i would say that cooking is kind of
what i do to
de-stress and usually i just have fun
with it
and like i mean to be honest i do more
baking and sorry more cooking than
baking which i guess it's not
an exact science like you don't really
worry too much about it
um one and a half loops okay
but i would say that both of them are
quite nice way i can open this
okay got it with my left hand that's
very nice right
but yeah usually i just like de-stressed
with cooking
and um how many subs do i need to get
like how many subs are you guys offering
for me to drink this whole thing because
it has to be a lot
oh yeah i got a cameraman today i have
like some people here like i said
uh i need like some supervision
uh to make sure that i don't set
something on fire
right right so i think this is all
mixed i think i'm going to like quickly
mix it to make sure that everything is
incorporated
because i don't want like flour or
powder to come up
when i use the hand mix that is over
there so
i just i don't know i'm always terrified
of that i see it in the movies
and yeah
anyways um i remember when i was i was
like practicing to do this at home
and i don't have a hand mixer or at
least i didn't have at the time
and um
yeah so i had to do it by hand and then
it sucked because
um it wasn't that smooth or
as good right now we're going to do the
same with this
let me maybe i should have done both at
the same time but i thought that it
would be too difficult
now like lose track of things i don't
know if this happens to other people
that stream i don't know if there is
anyone in the chat
that like streams or has had any
experience with it
but personally i think that you lose
like half of your brain cells when
you're streaming because you're like
paying attention to so many things
so i feel like it would be just like a
general struggle for me to
um bake and cook at the same time
we got one third what is one third
yeah about there that's fine
i think yep
cool
yeah i'm making a chest cake like i was
saying so essentially it just means that
um i'm gonna be making two cakes one of
them is chocolate and this one is
vanilla
and they're going to
like bake separately and eventually
we're going to like cut into them
do like surgery almost and mix them
so that when you open them it kind of
looks like
a checkerboard oh my god no did i get
shell on that
maybe i did yeah
it's fine it's for crunch right should
be okay
yeah it's fine
i'll use the excuse that i don't like
cook with eggs that much
because i don't like them so
do you guys have like a favorite dessert
or something
no i'm not doing a cake slime well most
i can do you is accepting challenges but
a saimo
i struggle with that on its own there's
no way
there's no way i'm making doing a slime
all at the same time
um so yeah
um yeah we're still we're still in
theory so that's all good
it's better than in my actual games
usually in my games i just
kind of wing it and uh maybe if i have
like some
theory from like five years ago things
are good
although recently i've been getting to
chessable courses which i think are
pretty nice for theory and especially
once you know someone goes back to
playing tournaments i feel like
trustable is like a really easy way to
to check and make sure because you know
they have like the system where they
force you to make moves
so i don't know if you guys have ever
like checked out chessable right before
playing but i think it's a good prep
um idea of course if you're like
confident in the
in the uh i guess like in the chessable
that you are
purchasing
cool i don't want to use this
[Music]
in my house you know we're very cheap so
we don't like to use paper towels that
much but
yeah it should be fine right
here i can do whatever i want not really
but you know let's pretend i come
what courses am i doing currently i'm
doing the
neighborhood one with um geary i think
it's very
like well-known and it's pretty good and
i also got the
i think i believe it's called lifetime
repertoire with
um the groomfeld and
swiddler yeah those are the two that i'm
doing right now
once i finish them i'll i'll buy more
but i do i do really like those two
okay i think it's time to use the hand
mixer
and i think i have to go there to do
that so
um i hope that you guys like the noise
what if i do like an asmr that'll be
[Music]
that would be terrible i talk too much
anyways i think i'm gonna like take this
over there
and it should i it should be on frame
i hope i don't know what's gonna happen
it's fine so i'm gonna talk through
through this right that's how you're
supposed to do it also i haven't used a
hand mixer in like years
[Music]
it's not too bad
i thought it would be worse i don't know
if you can hear me but like i thought it
would be worse
[Music]
okay i put it higher instead of
turning it off anyways what i didn't
think about it is that now i gotta use
this
for the other one which is fine i can
probably just like wash it or something
all right
do you really wash it or do you just
like you can take things out
and wash it don't wash it
no i mean like can't i just like put it
on the other cake
it'll be fine yeah i'll be fine i don't
i don't need to i need to clean it it's
fine
i hope this is like some realistic
cooking because this is how it is at my
house otherwise i'll be very embarrassed
if it wasn't
realistic um but yeah
anyway so this is perfect now i don't
know if i should
yeah it's fine let me just swindle this
here and
i hope i can put this here and not make
such a big mess
it's perfect it's fine now i'll bring
this one
over here um
what are we cooking it's a chess cake
it's fine
yeah i don't know who cares about it
yeah
uh chess of all courses on the ready
opening i don't know because i don't
play it with either color
so i mean i'm pretty sure that it would
be
also ready it's like extremely popular
nowadays
uh you can probably take a look at some
games
for example
nepomniacci against alexenko
in the candidates napoleon shoe with the
white pieces i feel like that's a pretty
good
example of how they're ready can go
wrong for black so
you can just take a look at it and you
know
even if you don't have a course you can
probably just go to like
um chess base
and you know browse through the
reference and you should be able to find
like um what the common moves are and i
would say that the writing in general is
not like
so heavy on aggressive chests so you can
probably have like flexible
options in it which is fine and actually
since i've
just finished a tournament um
since i just finished a tournament i saw
a bunch of people playing the ready
opening
over the board so i feel like in general
you know once we go back to playing
tournaments more often
um you're gonna see people play like
more casual openings like not so
mainline openings because they do
really work well in blitz and stuff
so i mean i'm not saying that the
writing is not mainline of course it is
but i mean like openings that provide
like no
issues to white openings that are very
calm it's what i'm trying to say
so yeah
yeah please donate and i'll mail you the
cake i mean
i'm pretty sure i can do that to the uk
yeah definitely
i can do that so i don't know what the
rules are
with this glass bowl i hope that i can
mix
stuff in it but
if it breaks then we'll get views right
so that's that's just how it is so
so far so good
[Music]
okay that looks like good enough
nice so now i think i gotta take these
two thingies
and uh it's plugged in maybe
i need to unplug it first and i
should take off this like two thingies
it also has a button that says turbo and
i didn't press it but now i'm
kind of tempted about it and you take
these two thingies
and you put them in the
sink and then you wash them not gonna do
it now but at the end i'll do it
that's why i tell my mom every time i
never do it
um all right let me just bring this here
and just get a
paper towel and i think we should
probably put this
on the other side too and i should
probably clean that surface because it
looks bad
and maybe i should just like wash it
as a whole probably i should wash it
yeah i did put x here
just in case i don't see any of it but
it does feel weird not doing that so
let me just maybe i should just like
quickly
that's fine that's perfect and
now we go to the next part which is
putting the cakes in the
pans and then putting them in the oven
the oven
um we had some funny moments with the
oven
before sorry where we didn't know if it
would like
work or not because apparently it's not
being used much
and i was saying i have a theory that i
think is correct
the chess players are not the best cooks
maybe today would be like the
the best way to prove this theory
but um anyway so apparently this oven
hasn't been used that much so
that's that's cool that's interesting
i don't know why i just came to mind
that i never explained where i was so
i could just be in like someone some
warehouse
this is just some one patch of like you
know some warehouse on the outsides of
san luis where no one ever goes
uh missouri i should say like outside of
missouri when no one ever goes
all right let me just bring this back
here
and then i'm gonna bring
this here and we're gonna put them
in the pans
um hannah's brain while we're baking
no ah no that's that's terrible
um that's terrible
it's my birthday no it's very far from
it i've said it before
those who who knows who knows where my
when my birthday is
because you should know very proud of it
i'm very proud of my zodiac sign
um
what am i cooking i'm doing a chess cake
and i'm going to put them in the pan and
are there chestable courses on the kings
indian
i believe so if now there are some good
books by boligan for example
so yeah
yeah i'm a sagittarius i'm born in
november so it's like very far from my
birthday
um where do i have the pants oh over
there
do we ever get baking paper yes
oh oh this perfect
perfect perfect um let me put this
here and then let me
ah let's just do one at a time so that
doesn't get too messy
and let me take this away because we're
not using it anymore i guess i can just
throw it away
and um
yeah do you guys have any funny stories
from your kitchen
i feel like i don't know i was just
saying earlier that i almost
well i've almost set things on fire a
lot before
and one time i um
i learned the hard way that you're not
supposed to mix
hot oil with water and
i kind of slightly made a fire and then
i got
like burnt on my hand right here and i
was
going to tell my mom like hey you know i
did this
but nothing happened and she was like
show me your arms and then i
and then i did but it wasn't physical it
was like over text so i just sent her a
photo and what i was like
kind of hiding my hand and then and then
later when we met like in person
and we went to the store she still
didn't know that i had that i also had
like a hoodie on and i was trying to
cover it
and we went to the store with to buy
some
jeans or something and i was in the
fitting room and then somehow
while i was putting on clothes i just
accidentally slammed my head into the
mirror
of the of the of the changing
uh room thing and somehow the mirror
didn't have edges so i caught myself in
the exact same place
where i had the burn and then i could
fake that it was all from the coin
that i never burned myself i never told
my mom that i
that i burned myself i don't have a mark
or anything so i guess that's pretty
lucky but that's one of my stories in
case you're wondering
um yeah so
that's how it is one time i put a bag of
soft taco shells
from chipotle in the microwave and
forgot that there was metal in the bag
which started a little fire but it was
put out quickly okay
that's cool that's fine if it was put
out quickly that's fine
wait how do i do this right
think maybe i need to fold it
also i'm not exactly sure when my bosses
chose me
to do this thing i feel like there can
be more qualified people to do all of
this
um but my boss was like you know if it
sucks it's even better more views and
more
content you know so that's that's
very you know it feels nice when your
boss says that
and um yeah so now i gotta do
this to make it fit which i am
a little bit insecure about but it'll be
fine that's what i say right i always
say that
it'll be fine sorry if it's making a lot
of noise
uh but i always say that things will be
fine and usually they are so that's
that's good
this is okay is this how you do it i'm
not sure you're just like
you have ben over there going like i
don't know
i'm the wrong person
do you think that this is okay to put
them
yeah that doesn't sound very confident
um it should be fine
yeah yeah we'll be fine
now i gotta pour this in here which is
the fun part
oh no the spoons are in the washer oh no
well i can use
like this that's fine this will do
um they are saying ben can't bake or
cook
he just said the status that's right
[Laughter]
oh wait hold up i need to mix a little
this because i just threw flour in there
from the bottom but it's fine it's all
fine
no more i'm worried that this is too big
i hope it isn't if it's if it's a thing
cake
then that's fine because um i probably
needed to cut it anyways so
someone is talking outside i wonder what
they're talking about
probably they're looking at here and
they're like what's going on
i thought they were just people
anyways we're gonna try and get all of
what's in there
so that um first of all you got more
cake
and second of all um
there's no second of all
um
yeah we're entering the middle game
right now that's pretty cool right
i mean we got through the opening that's
usually the toughest part getting
through those uh
um fried livers fried liver exactly what
you want to hear in a baking stream
um oh isn't there like some chocolate
variation or something
not um remind that is it like e4 f5
takes king f7 is that what the chocolate
is i'm not sure i think i heard it when
i was a child and i never heard about it
again
which makes sense it's not real but
recently i learned that there was a
thing called the traxler i didn't know
that was a thing
but i mean um there are many openings
that i don't know of
so yeah
me being embarrassed in cooking i'm not
particularly like
extremely embarrassed but i mean um
if this goes terrible then i will be a
little bit embarrassed
um all right so i think i got like most
of it out
i'm gonna try and scrape the bowl a
little bit
one of my proudest baking creations i
made a tres leches
cake ones but it was actually like a
four leches because i used
um like dulce de leche on top which is
condensed milk that you burn pretty much
it's really good so that's that's the
one thing that i know how to do best
i feel like i didn't do this right
maybe it's okay maybe this goes here and
then this goes on top of it
and then you scrape it to the edges
benny's overseeing this like what is she
doing
it'll be fine
sorry i kind of uh put the same
intensity on this that i do for my games
that's not true but let's pretend it is
talking about that i just finished a
tournament i didn't do very well in it
but you know that's how it is sometimes
i played chicago open shout out to you
if you played chicago open i did meet
some people
um online i mean that i know online
add the chicago open so that was pretty
cool
um i think this one is good but i want
to put them in the oven at the same time
just to make sure that like
there is no
unevenness right
so let's just put this over here for now
and then let's take the other one of
this guys
and try to fold it again in a way that
doesn't look terrible
yeah chicago was an over the board
tournament which is nice it's funny
because it's like compared to last year
compared to last year you see so many
people nowadays using
like merch from streamers which is nice
because you support streamers you know
but it's kind of funny to see because it
feels like you know chess grew so much
over this last year online and then now
you're seeing like
so many players with uh streamers merch
and
stuff like that so yeah
in germany you don't have any over the
board tournaments yet well hopefully
they can start
back up soon because it is very fun to
to play especially if you like develop
some new friendships online
over this year and then now you want to
you know
you can meet them so that's nice
you had four over the board games
yesterday in your kitchen
okay i don't know how that works but
it's not like i'm doing any better here
so that's fine um
yeah it's 2021 let's normalize uh
cooking in chess channels that's how it
is now
i mean it's uh does this make me a
variety streamer because i mean i could
be
for sure so yeah
thank you yeah i mean i am
a rather decent chess player i hope that
i can
bake something also you can't see but my
dress has like little cherries on them
it's a shame because i don't like them
but i mean i feel like
[Laughter]
so yeah let me just watch this real
quick
i feel like i'm getting water everywhere
and one thing that i forgot to say which
i believe like most of you kind of know
already
uh i'm reminded now because this patrol
my mom got for me
but um she
uh before we before i got here she was
like come on let me take you to the
store and then let me get you some
some um how did i just rip the paper
um let me get you some appliances right
for the show that you have to do today
she got really excited about it
and for those of you who don't know my
mom has a food truck here in san luis
it's called havana's cuisine
i feel like that's one that's that's uh
you know maybe we can't show brands on
this
on this channel but i feel like havana's
christine would definitely be a sponsor
of this right
yeah so that's fine for me to say right
[Music]
so i hope that there's there's no
problem with that
it's just my mom like i can just tell
her it's fine and
yeah it's not like she's gonna copyright
things or whatever
anyway so i'm gonna put this second
thing here let me just make sure that
it's
it seems to be well mixed so that's good
and
maybe i shouldn't have put it in because
now yeah
maybe i just yeah let's just pour it
and then i'm gonna this one's heavier
but it seems like it's going on so much
smoothly
um does this look satisfying
i mean it's i like it i like how it
looks
now i gotta handle this and then pour
this here but my hands are small and
they don't have enough strength to do
that
shout out to the people who have small
hands that's how it is sometimes
however i can hold an entire chest set
in my hands
both of them so i feel like that's
impressive in some extent
can you guys do that i don't know maybe
i have like way too much
time on my hands that i know i have that
skill
also when i went to this tournament in
chicago
you are kind of supposed to bring your
own chest set
um and i forgot that the chest that i
have in my travel bag
is the one that i use for like practice
right it's like let's say i'm prepping
in someone and i'm gonna do some
preparation
um and then i bring this the chest right
i forgot that i had to play with it
too and the thing is that
uh i have like a set of like
for a visual you know representation i
haven't said
you know when the pawns look like this
and then i have one random pawn that
looks like this
and my abundance were like so weird that
i'll buy it and then when they realized
it was like because
usually i put on a or h file and then
when they realize it's like oh wait let
me trade it and yeah
it was it was kind of funny it was just
one chunky part
it was hilarious okay anyway so
i think i got the two cakes ready i'm
gonna put this away real quick
and then we can
put them in the oven and um
i don't know what comes after that but
yeah
also the oven is down here it seems hot
so i hope that like it was actually
doing
the job that the oven is supposed to do
we're a bit worried because it it
kind of smelled a little bit burnt when
we turned this on but i think it should
be
should be okay my mom also got me over
mitts but who uses those anyways i mean
after being emotionally discouraged so
many times by losses you kind of
lose all sense of touch anyways so let
me just put this here
and let me get this one
and then we put both of them at the same
time and then we wait for like
i don't want to say like a specific
amount of time because it's never
specific
i don't care if a recipe tells you like
some specific time
it never is you know you just poke
uh a fork i don't have a toothpick i
should probably ask for it
but you can just poke a fork and then
you figure out you know
from then uh if it's cooked or not
because if it has like batter in the
fork
when you stick it out you can use a fork
or a knife both of them work
um but not a sharp knife because then it
loses the sharpness
anyway so when you just like stick
something in
if it has batter in it then it's not
ready and if it comes out clean then
it's all fine
so that's usually how i know
but yeah uh what is my
favorite opening as
black and white that i like to play
huh with the white pieces
i don't know exactly i really like the
four pawns
i feel like it's very against the quincy
and i feel like it's very interesting
um also this damage i quite like i think
i have good results with it i played
this crazy game on my last round of the
tournament
in the sandwich it was so good and with
the black pieces
i just like the neidorf why because i
have an emotional attachment to it is it
sane probably not neither has so many
variations like it's impossible for me
to learn everything
and something new is happening every day
like literally when
um kirwana beat mvl
in the candidates for like like two days
later i got
some some lines in that same variation
um from white it was the bishop g5 with
some c3 novelty
and i was like huh people are really
learning and you know there are always
so many lines it's so extent but i mean
it's really fun to play and it does
really bring your chances in case you're
um
needing them in your tournament
situation so
i really like those openings uh
eventually i'll get into playing e4
but for now i just play d4 as usual
oh right i should probably have a timer
for this i don't know how to do it here
um but i can just set a timer on my
phone and i hope it'll be fine
yeah we can check in like 20 minutes
uh yeah right so i think since i'm not
doing anything right now
later we can do like whatever in case i
should have been doing it now
um but we can play some games now in
case you guys want
so you can feel free to challenge
in case you want so yeah
wait is this not the same louis chess
club
oh okay i mean yeah please challenge
this
chess club like that's the that's the
one account that you know
i have here so that makes sense
oh would you look at that i already have
some challenges this is like the
this is like the you know like the
the little challenge accepted that i do
after
ladies class on thursdays but i'm doing
it now on a wednesday
wednesdays are weird days and you never
think about it and
and
you thought you would learn a new recipe
look at my games look at these two
bishops that i'm about to
develop i mean that that that's the
recipe for disaster for my opponent
i was so stupid anyways i'm comfortable
with the position that i have
um yeah this is not a gaming stream
exactly so
i mean that's just that's just how it is
this is why this is what a variety
streamer can do for you okay so um
yeah that's just how it is so uh
let me bring the stroke over here you
guys can see the board and the time and
everything fine
right all right now i have two pawns in
the center
my two bishops are kind of pointing in
that direction
kind of tempted to do some d5 stuff
so that i can you know open up the other
bishop and have
some tricks but i don't know if it's too
early to do that
i don't know if it's too early to do
that
i think i'm gonna put this rook to the
center and so that all of my pieces are
cohesive
and if he's gonna give me the bishop
pair i don't think i'm anyone to not
accept it
so yeah
all right let's bring our pieces up
and it almost feels like he has like a
little
space in the position like his pieces
can't
really comfortably go to places
and if he does this i think i managed to
like you know
have some stuff on this side of the
board now
so let's just jump up with the night
healthy not too dry position develop
yeah i generally like those setups
oh hold up we have some tricks i told
you the bishops
the bishops were the key and now i i
took that
i don't know how to proceed though
because he does have the bishop pair
even though i took the queen
and this bishop right here could be in a
better diagonal
but i mean it's a nice improvement i
think let me
probably bring this rook here so that i
can try to fight for some
you know activity on the file that's not
really something that i was expecting
through going over there let's go here
and hope that the two bishops are not
terrible
and let's hope that i also have some
sneaky threats right because
those are always nice
yeah exactly winning the queen is a nice
improvement that's that's
you know what we can call it a best
and now we have a mating too which is
nice
ggs cool
um as danish would say boom
nice all right so
gg's dwi now let's
play ufo ufo has some nice
uh greenfield prep but i'm also black
pieces in this game
imagine the the that i forget like
imagine that i'm doing this at home
in a much more casual way and
i completely like forget that i'm baking
and and then like an hour later i'm like
oh yeah i was baking cake
but i got to 2500 blitz so that's what
matters
uh that's the one roasting that we did
am i right
that's terrible all right um
like i said you know this bishop g5
neither if it's like becoming
i mean it's always popular but like
nowadays i feel like it's even more
popular
for me winning the queen is just a
normal developing move
that's how it is sometimes
yeah this is a poison pawn variation of
course we want the pawn to be poison and
not the cakes am i right
[Laughter]
they're not that great to be honest i
can try better for the spawns but
it's fine um okay
wait do i have knight takes here because
it does look nice
knight takes and then bishop takes and
i'm pawn here and then i go back
nothing is hanging and i did take his
bishop which is nice
i think i'm gonna go ahead and do that i
feel like usually you go bishop c2 and i
guess that's the reason why bishop c2
and then queen c7 that's usually how the
main line goes so it also works now
because my queen is not on d8
so you know it's not under attack
right now g3 and now we go back
i feel like you know if i just gain the
center it should be fine
also this is like a weird angle for me
because like it's too low
but i'm also very short so this is very
surprising
um but for someone that generally has
terrible posture this is you know make
it an even worse
anyways let's just develop our pieces
and be fine be solid
i hope that my hair is not getting to
the mic
um come on my friend chicago
um okay
i was saying that i probably lost a lot
of rain in chicago just now but that's
fine
usually in my tournaments i can lose a
ton of rating
and then in the next one gain it back
back up like it was nothing
so i'm not too worried it's just kind of
like
you know when you lose games or you do
badly in a tournament it's uh
you can cry about it you can be sad
about it there's nothing wrong with that
you can let out your emotions but at the
same time
you can kind of realize that maybe that
wasn't you the one that was playing
and that you can do so much better than
that
and that you know you just kind of need
to wake up again that's usually how
college is
waking up again so
um yeah
i don't know i think that it's not such
a big deal and
you can always do better and that
you know
how should i say this in a way like you
you probably shouldn't be sad about it
because you can do so much better in the
future
and it does kind of lead to some
emotional roller coasters when all of
your tournaments are like
plus 50 points minus 40 points you know
but that's how it is sometimes
i just gained like 50 points in my last
tournament so now i'm losing a ton too
so ah it'd be like that
to put the laptop on the kickstand oh
no this kickstand would that be a funny
idea probably not i'll probably ruin the
cables
um
so i oh i have this nice idea
what's happening with you guys today
it's like
um you guys are giving me your queens
this is so fun i get to
i get to uh bake the cake and eat it too
right
this is getting worse than it was
yeah yeah yeah
but okay um
yeah often do i get the
poison pawn variation of the night off
um
quite often actually if i have to pick
from
from like all of the all of the lines
that white can do on most sticks
i feel like it's very common to to play
the bishop g5 knight earth and
oftentimes i just kind of go for some
sidelines too like
for example in my tournament i had two
h3 knighters which i think it's not that
common
so sometimes you get those bishop e2 i
would say
is also quite popular and then those
english attack ideas are usually like
the
main thing i would say but it feels like
nowadays so many more people are playing
like
lines that are not necessarily bad
they're just very rare which can be good
like for example knight b3 or move six
um
a3 h4 h3 you know
all of this sideline ideas and you know
if you know them well they can be pretty
good so
that's the one thing about the niter if
it gives like so many options to white
so yeah
but okay ggs ufo um
i don't know if they i don't know if i
should chunk on them
already or not probably not probably
they're okay in there
okay
that's a lie the kitchen smells the same
i can smell it you can smell it it
smells like cake really oh i
smell nothing okay that's probably a
problem
all right let's go to the next challenge
now we got five minutes which is cool
actually the one played against the one
game i played against the gm
i got to play against shavalov in the
tournament
great guy by the way um
it was a dutch so i'm just reminded of
it now
yeah caleb did a whole series on the
night there's a lot of content out there
that you can
get for it like caleb did a series you
can go to chester ball and find the giri
uh series chess space had a really
really nice
um naido of course with kasparov many
years ago
um yeah there are a ton of options you
know
you can look and find worst case
scenario you can
go through the neither of with the book
or with
just the opening database and why i
don't recommend books on this time
is that you know the neither of kind of
uh evolves
very quickly so maybe a book is a little
bit outdated
but if you find a book that has like
general plans for certain positions it
can be nice
although like i said you know plans
change and evolve so yeah
let's take here and then i'm gonna
castle
probably put my knight on c3 play knight
of four knight d3
stuff like that so yeah
worst cake scenario very nice you guys
are getting you guys are getting
my uh you know we're connecting our
brain cells
to maybe form one by the end of the
string
um so yeah
see you later manny you can re-watch the
stream later and uh know if i
burn the kitchen or not yeah
um also i believe that
should i say that this will be turn
yeah it does return into a youtube video
later which is like hopefully edit it so
i don't look like an idiot
so so you know you can also watch that
eventually when it comes out
um so yeah
knight f4 i like that i'm doing this
with the tempo on the bishop
probably they want to go back this way
but i'll keep on developing like normal
ah that feels a little weird
it feels as if it shouldn't be right but
i don't know if i want to take so
quickly because you know
my knight is better than that bishop so
i think i'm going to develop this knight
first
um who knows maybe i haven't thought
exactly of the decoration that i'm gonna
do on the cake so maybe if i have like
some luck
i can like put a certain opening on the
top
um
okay now that castle long which is
like another thing that i'm not so sure
about
it doesn't feel correct well what should
i do
hmm
what should i do here i feel like i
should get my bishop out of the way but
there is no like good square to do that
just yet
so
hmm i'm gonna go rook here with the idea
of b4
i don't care if he takes the pawn
because it opens up the files
so yeah
um
st louis cake club oh that's funny
i like that all right let's just go on
the attack i could also play knight g6
but i think that's not necessary right
now let's just you know
push push push and
see what happens
hmm
okay so he took with the bishop now i'm
gonna go knight here
and the good thing is that now this file
is open so
maybe i can play like a3 and queen b3
now i'm starting to smell it now i'm
starting to smell it does smell quite
nice here now
yeah three minutes
okay i'll check on them after this game
is done
or i could do both at the same time it's
my opponent's turn
i wonder do we have oh i should show you
guys the knives that we have here
look i didn't bring any of them from
home but look at this this one's pretty
nice right
we have some knives here like i said you
probably don't want to use a sharp knife
i
believe this one's for like vegetables
and stuff um
but you don't usually want to use like a
sharp knife to
stop the cake um you would usually
just want to use like a regular one i
imagine we have some of those yeah this
is this is fine this one's better
um okay my opponent made a move so i
should probably do something
if i go h a3 he can go knight c3 when i
play takes takes queen b3
and it's all great so that's probably
fine yeah let's go a3
um yeah
let's stop the cake a little bit and see
how it's going
um damn it these rocks are like too
close to each other
i don't know how to do this without
breaking something
i feel like it's not done yet but
oh it's more cooked than i expected okay
i'm not even gonna touch the other one
that's fine let's just put this
where is it not on frame if i put it
here will it be fine yeah let's put it
there
um okay so i also have bishop e4 and
knight c5 which does look pretty nice
in fact i think i'll play it um
yeah and then i may be winning a piece
so that's cool
don't slap the laptop don't worry i
wouldn't do that
um i didn't know that carlson slammed
his computer once
one time i was hanging out with someone
like doing some chess work
this is very funny um i was doing some
chess work with someone
and then we're both staring at a
position right because we're analyzing
on the computer it was his computer
right
and then all of a sudden you know with a
serious face we're both calculating on
the position he goes
and then he just like you know hits the
computer and then he's like
gosh i hate this so much i couldn't stay
in the hotel because i couldn't afford
it so i went to go
i went to to my family's house right but
then my aunt she was here at the same
time and she got the bed
so i had to sleep in the sofa and i feel
like death i hate everything
and i was like okay wait what
how does that involve me like why are
you telling me and
it was just it was just you know
just a funny day lots of unexpected
stuff
anyways i think i should take an intake
on e6 and i'm doing pretty good
i think he he left like a little tent or
something on his computer it was it was
interesting um yeah
yeah it was just very unexpected i
wasn't really expecting it
um now i take this and i believe i'm a
piece up i don't think i want to take
with the other knight just so that this
doesn't hang
but you know it's kind of a winning
position so
i feel like this should be in there
based on my
non-baker estimate um for like maybe 10
more minutes
so but i'll see the the
white cake did look quite nice already
also like how do you ever tell that a
chocolate cake is done because it's like
if it burns you can't really see it so
he almost choked
no but like for real like how how do you
know is it like until
you smell like it getting burnt
um yeah i know i'm supposed to poke it
that's why
that's what i did i don't have a
toothpick so i used a knife
um but yeah i i know that
it's just that you know sometimes you
just wonder like how how do you know
okay let's just go here with the rook
and now this is just technique to win
the game
because i already have a piece up so if
there
goes to d8 i probably trade if he takes
with either piece i guess i can take on
h5 which is nice so
yeah i'll probably do i'll probably do a
stream on this later maybe for tomorrow
thursday
but i had this one game at chicago open
which was just insane it was my last
round game
i did briefly mention it before
um on my discord so i'm very active on
discord
but i didn't mention that um
i had this one game that was very wild
and um it started as a sammich
right against the kings indian and after
i played the sandwich
i was going to be i was going to i was
thinking you know like
crap maybe i should have played the four
pawns because it's more aggressive it's
the last round of the tournament i don't
care anymore
and i was like well that was a missed
opportunity
and then i got the craziest game
oh that's a timer oh
i don't think it's done though um
let me just take
this and then let me clean this up
and is it my turn oh yeah it is my turn
sorry we care more about the game than
the cake the cake can burn but i need to
win this game
otherwise our rating will be burnt
okay let's try this again
hopefully the cake doesn't drop
oh it's so much better than before
nice okay now let's try the other one i
think the other one may be done
also wait i have one minute here um
oh i could take this spawn and then have
this um
yeah let's take this guy oh we have
plus um two second incoming okay i can
win this with that
and let me put this back here
and
wait hold up ah i need to win this
and then pre-move this wait no primo's
allowed
on this computer what
no primos allowed
okay i'll just win the game real quick
hopefully or maybe not i don't know
i mean my instinct is to just straight
everything down and then eventually when
um oh i
do i see a nice technique no i can just
take the spawn
and then go back or something
and i take this guy too that's nice
and probably shouldn't leave the oven
open for this long
okay now i have this perfect and then i
take this
and yeah let me check on the other cake
real quick
oh i think i almost burnt myself
oh the other one is not cooked at all
that's
not ideal okay wait hold up let me just
close that and
wait did the game end oh
okay the game ended cool i won that's
what matters
all right i think one of them we can
take out the other one we can't you see
it
i had some oven mitts somewhere oh here
here perfect
this is too big and too bothersome but
safety
yeah you think i use this at home
no i don't but my mom bought it because
she wants me to be professional
anyways yeah is it okay if i put it on
top of wood
like that should be fine right let me
just
push this to the side and move this like
here or something
ah yeah that's fine
oh no i can't get it with this okay i
got it
perfect
looks fine right i think it's done
i'm not sure now yeah i should leave it
on for
you it's good
well you're the expert
[Laughter]
all right um
i've got to tie my shoes no i i don't
have shoe laces i'm wearing heels
what do you think i look so tall right
now um
either way i think we should probably
leave this other one on but lower the
heat a little bit if i know how to do
that
i'm not exactly sure how that is done
very confused
um it's not cooking time
bake and now it says
um um
oh i think i got it let's put it on 300
and then start perfect
oh my god i'm so good at this
no this don't go here this probably
should go like here or something
and i should probably let this set um i
don't know if i should put it on like
the
fridge or the fridge is a little scary
um yeah
anyways so i think
i think what's best is to put it on the
fridge so i don't know if it's not even
hot
why did i even bother um
that's fine it's not hot but okay
yeah i think we should probably put it
in the fridge
i don't know what that sound was
thank you be careful it might be hot
[Laughter]
the lights
[Music]
thank you
anyways yeah this is great um
yeah perfect it's all going perfect um
yeah so we let this cake like sit in
there it doesn't i don't know if it's
baking or not
i think it is because it says on
so that should indicate that it's good
right
you know who you know who was also
surprised by the cooking show talia
yesterday yeah i thought it was on
saturday i forgot that it was today
yeah but yeah it's fine it's fine um
how are we supposed to know if you look
tall well i could take my high heels off
and then
i'll be like this maybe um
but yeah anyways so
let's just continue with some challenges
while the other cake is
finished baking and then eventually i
think we can take that one out of the
fridge
hopefully with less struggles and put it
here and now we're going to start
cutting it and leveling it and all of
that so
i'll just take another challenge in the
meantime should i
accept a casual challenge i feel like
usually i accept just rated
i don't know that's what tracy tells me
to do and i never do it
um let's
just go for this casual
all right are you guys enjoying the
stream this is not my usual content but
it's also like
same vibe i think you know
okay let's just are we gonna get a
groomfield
oh i forgot to tell you guys because i
was doing all of this but i forgot to
tell you yeah the game that i played
on my last run of chicago open so
interesting
um i had like a
crazy position out of the
middle game and
it almost looked like i was about to
check my opponent but it never actually
happened
and also
yeah let's do that and also
we eventually traded down into an indie
game
and the end game we had like
seven past poems total or something
all in different files it was insane
i think it was the a file the only one
that didn't have a passport
and i also had like one minute it was
all you know very chaotic but it was
very fun
yeah okay i think i'm gonna go here
um i don't know if i want to allow takes
maybe i should just
like go back or play b5 i don't see h5
is like such a big
worry
maybe h5 you know
it's okay doesn't look like a huge deal
if he takes i just take it and that that
looks okay
he did give up his bishop though which
is fine perfect so he didn't do that
and now i could go here perhaps
and then when the bishop goes back i go
bishop f5
oh never mind now i just get to take
this and i feel like i have a lot less
worries once he doesn't have the
pair of bishops so that's cool let's go
here i wonder what he's gonna do with
his king
i think i can castle and i'll be fine
play like knight g4 or something
um yeah
and then you know if he takes i take and
if he plays f3 knight e3 is hanging and
i also have ideas of f6 e5
which i think are good in general like
or i guess
e5 right away i mean the point here is
that you need to find some sort of
counter play as black
or like a way to open up the position
because white's king is also
kind of iffy so
[Music]
i guess we could do this right away
takes and then d4 maybe but i also
kind of want to play f6 first so that i
kicked this knight out
maybe just this right away is the best
continuation
i'm not sure
i'm thinking about e5 and then if f6 one
takes one takes bishop takes and then
you take on c3
which i think is fine yeah let's
just see what happens
i got a notification here in the
computer that says um either restart now
or wait an hour
would you imagine um do i just click on
wait an hour and then
see like i hope it doesn't like
accidentally you know without telling me
restarts or something
yeah also how is this cake doing
it looks better
you're not supposed to open it that many
times because it releases the steam
but um
you know no one cares okay
knight takes and now this position i
would say looks quite solid
you resent yours as rated okay i'll i'll
check out the challenge later i'll try
to go in order of
the people who challenge you know but
we'll see so i think i'll go here again
and now i just in the future i have some
ideas of this
oh actually i could eventually like put
my bishop on this diagonal it would be a
good diagonal for it
but yeah
don't say takes say cake
okay that's gonna be hard
but this position looks fine
and uh hopefully you know he
makes a mistake okay a4 i wasn't
concerned i don't know i thought that he
would like castle or something
um could play queen f6 i guess
could play queen f6
rookie one also makes sense if you think
about it
there is a rookie one in madriga eight
but okay i think i'm gonna go here
just to you know put some pressure on
the spawn and
still i'm kind of asking the king what
it wants to do because if it castles
long you just played a4 so maybe i can
play like even b5 or something
ah so he castled short
but now i feel like i can have some
tricks
i'm not sure if that would work but
you know some tricky ideas
do you use steak steak steaks or kkk
by eric rosen that should be put into a
mixtape
that comes out this summer
oh it's okay i just pressed cl um check
back on me in an hour
and then hopefully i'll do that
okay i can go bishop here and bishop
here and to be honest that does look
quite nice so i don't see why i
shouldn't play it also i'm developing my
piece which is good
um one kind of drawback of when you play
h4 is that oftentimes
g4 can be
like a good spot for a piece same way
that you know
it was g5 but at the same time i feel
like you know g5 you may not have as
many threats also i can kick it away
easier
because i don't have a pawn on the e
file and you do so if you play f3 that's
going to weaken that
but i would say that my position looks
quite nice right now
i don't know hopefully the cake is going
it's nice
okay perfect so now i do have some ideas
of this
but i don't think they quite
work just yet unfortunately
i could go here i guess but i still
don't know what that does
let's just unpop the pressure and double
up the rooks
because i can
so far i don't think taking here quite
works oh wait
maybe i had some crazy idea i was like
take some bishop d3 or something
but i don't i don't know it still looks
a bit sketchy so
um yeah
kg2 that also looks quite sketchy but
i'm just gonna bring my rook over
at least now i don't have like the 93
queen g3 stuff right
my position looks really nice now
this thing could be very annoying if he
doesn't do anything about it
maybe i'm going to swing my queen to
this side now
and it'll look nice
i don't know if i have a better move but
this looks quite good
oh i don't know if that was the best
okay maybe he had f3 and i didn't
consider that deeply enough
now i'll swing my stuff to the edge fire
and i think i can win with g5 for
example
i could trade and i could also not trade
in fact i'm threatening rook takes h4
maybe even quintix h4 that would be
funny
what am i cooking it's a chess cake
yeah i was i was explaining my hatred
for x back when i was doing that step
um i mean it makes sense
all right did the did the game finished
i think so because neither time is
running so
ggs ggs oh yeah i did finish it set up
top
sorry the design here is a little weird
but yeah now that we're done let's check
the cake again and see if it's not burnt
it is not perfect
oh it's clean that's nice
perfect it's perfect um
cool what happens if i get it out with
my hands
not that hot it's not okay
i should stop messing around let me just
get this
um yeah if my mom got them for me i
should probably wear them so that i know
i
don't uh you know i told a story earlier
for those of you who were here i told
the story earlier of how
i accidentally burped myself and i
disguised it by
accidentally turning it into a cut
anyways
i don't want to do that again with my
mom so
let's just um look at how cute it looks
oh my gosh perfect
it is not burned yeah because burn you
know he had like
this very unfortunate game against bobby
fischer
although we're not doing fish today
we're just doing cakes
stupid okay i was going to rip the paper
out but i can't do that so i probably
would need to put this in the oven
i probably need to put this not in the
oven in this
um and then maybe take the other one out
if you want i can
i can try to help we probably need to
get the one
in the fridge out and then put this one
here um do you want the oven mitts
yeah yay
i feel a little insecure with the fact
that it has a crack on it
also it's kind of hot at the bottom so
maybe we should just
put it back and like wait a little bit
because yeah because i don't want it to
be hot because if it's hot then it's
going to be a lot harder to
cut so maybe you know maybe just let it
chill there for a moment
yeah it'll be fine no there's no fish
stream
i'm not i'm not eating fish i'm not
confused
consuming fish i'm not fishing i i won't
do any of those things
although if you pay me enough anything's
possible
i can go to missouri river or something
and then just like hang out there in the
corner
um i'm gonna pause these cameras and
we'll just we'll just stream exclusively
until the cakes are ready
that's okay uh i don't know what that
means
well yeah we're just doing the cakes
right now
yeah we're not doing kicks right now
yeah that's fine
um yeah above the fishing stream in the
in the mississippi river yeah exactly
that's that's you know
maybe maybe one day we're gonna get to
that derailed moment
anyways let's go to the next challenge
okay now i'm just gonna be playing and
talking
for a bit until the cakes are um chilled
so yeah
oh we're going to get another night off
oh never mind
this needs to become a thing on foot
networks from now on
i haven't watched food networks in like
a really long time
didn't they didn't they uh you know get
a lot of hate because they made like
this really weird popcorn salad have you
heard of it
it's like they got popcorn and then they
put in like mayo and then like
like a imagine like a potato salad but
with popcorn instead of potatoes it was
really weird they said that it was a
very common traditional jummy thing but
it's just weird
and they got a lot of hate for it so
yeah that's that's what i can remember
from from food network anyways you know
great channel um all right let me just
uh
focus on this game for a bit i think i
can play e6 because if you take take
take
i can just develop my queen and there is
no problem
so i'm gonna do this right now
and hope that i didn't blunder like a
bishop takes or something
yeah farsan remembers he knows what i'm
talking about yeah
anyways i believe now we're just going
to like do some natural development and
then
you know get our pieces out regular
sicilian stuff
um
oh yeah the oven still maybe i should
turn it off um
okay i pressed clear off and kind of
stopped doing what i was doing
okay let's go here and hope that it's
fine
it might start a food war i've never
been in one of those you know how like
in movies sometimes like those high
school movies they show that then
suddenly out of nowhere they have like a
food bottle at the cafeteria
i've never been in one of those and i
feel like i would excel because i have
really good aim
so i just feel like it would be like it
would be
you know i would be decent at those
but for real i have really good aim i
i always hit the eyes somehow um
and when i'm in the eye i'm in my
sister's eye but
you know it's a
it's a quality i am proud of so yeah
anyways uh this position
i don't want it to get a little too out
of hand
maybe i should do this
then you know eventually get this night
out oh my sister is here
hi how are you doctor siegel
i didn't think you would tune in
that's my sister everyone dark j siegel
here in the chat
yeah she can confirm right
that b4 is a bit annoying
but i think i can take i don't know what
the risk is but i mean after takes takes
takes
how bad can it be i'm just upon up and
there is no concrete attack on my king
so let's go for it
my sister really likes the bob ross um
emote it doesn't make sense because she
paints
um wait i find it cute anyways
let's push the spawn consolidate this
knight
if he plays f3 i just go back i think
yeah we're cooking today in case that
someone just got here and doesn't
understand what's going on
and this is all
part of the new exhibition that they
have at the
world chess hall of fame called check
please and it's funny because we were
talking a few streams ago when i found
out that they were
changing the spots you know for for
um kingside diner we were doing like uh
some talks you guys remember
uh some of the some of the chess player
inspired food menu item names that we
were talking
about um yeah
because it was it was a fun time you
know we came up with so many names
like well i don't want to say them right
now because it's embarrassingly stupid
but you know we came up with some good
names right
wait can i take this guy maybe i could
yeah do you guys remember
yeah what were some of the names
how do you feel about sarah wantons
yeah it does sound good right yeah based
on sarah one
let's castle
and i feel like you know it's all safe
after a castle
maybe somehow you can mix like
quesadillas with you know
gm cassava you know little details like
that
it would be fun though i mean
i am chicken and rose and mary that's
that's cool
um
rose and mary that's funny
but okay this position is also very
funny
looking
oh yeah garrick asparagus that's funny
too
by the way i mean no offense to this
player they're all extremely good it's
just what the name is kind of sound
alike
um yeah
bobby fish and chips okay i like that
one that one's cool
anyways yeah we came out with some of
those
um yeah it was it was a solid idea
i heard that they have a drink named
after fabian another one after
kasparov which is you know quite nice
too very
yeah he says are great i haven't had
them of course
but he says they're good
all right so this is something that i
missed actually
um let's see i could go look here and
then he would take probably
oh okay i'll be back cool
let's see how do i deal with this mess
is there an increment on this no i don't
know
maybe i should just like go here
since i still have a nice position
um
what should i do
oh there is no increment oh
it'll be fine it'll be fine
yeah bishop c3 was a nice move
but it still looks quite fine right now
oh wait this one is hanging i forgot
about that
oh
let's see what's going on with this game
because i have no clue but it seems like
my opponent is thinking so it's like
giving me some time
oh i don't know if that was a good idea
or not
maybe it wasn't
oh doesn't look good now
maybe i can have like some tricks in the
position
but i still have like no time
oh they have even less time
but i have no primus oh
okay
hi i'm manny the cakes the cakes are in
the fridge right now
are onion drinks okay that's funny um
yeah ggs uh i think i got a little
carried away earlier
but thankfully i don't think i was like
completely lost at any point
although there was like this nice idea
of 96 maybe i could have
played against it better
maybe there was bishop c6 now bishop c3
oh that was
way simpler than when what i ended up
doing
yeah bishop c3 is probably winning
but yeah ggs okay so far so good today
um
should i check on the cakes to see how
they're doing
i feel like maybe not yet i don't know
i'm confused by the times
let's play let's play one more and then
i'll check on the cakes
maxine bashar lasagna okay that's
i don't know if that's you know that's
interesting
okay now we got a nimso no i guess like
a queen's indian
type of thing exactly chess plus cooking
what could go wrong
nothing nothing can go wrong here
vampire chicken salad
you guys are getting creative with this
fish stock soup at a petrossian it's
gonna be in vegas
so that's funny
if he wins a tournament he'll make a
bunch of uh
gm's peeping their pamper you guys know
what i'm talking about
you do you know what i'm talking about
oh okay
there's a lot of two on [ __ ]
it's a long story
nigel short ribs
well the joke is i mean
i hope i'm allowed to say it but the
joke is essentially that
um i think it was like last year
when they were doing tournaments online
they were doing pro league last year or
something
but roshan was very suspicious you know
the guy from
armenia yeah so it's the joke and then
the reply that he did to wesley so after
he kind of you know uh pointed fingers
and patrocian said that he was uh
he was already beating gm's when wesley
was doing peeping his pampers and that
just became a joke
yeah you know what i'm talking about now
yeah yeah okay
that's what i meant everyone knows about
it
cervantes cervezas okay i like that that
could be a drink name
you know
um okay let's go
here
i would say that so far so good in this
position i can maybe put my knight on e5
you know
probably double up the rooks or
something
hi sean how are you
okay let's go night here sean was in
chicago so i think he had a pretty good
result
if there was a cervantes meal it would
come with bread
i don't understand that one i don't
actually eat that much bread but
sure
anise go cheese okay
okay at this point i just don't even
know what half of those uh
words mean but very creative
ah because miguel de cervantes once said
all sorts are less with bread
okay cool
i'm not related to him i feel like i
have to say that i'm like every every
time that someone sees my name
no i'm not related to a famous writer
okay let's go here with the rock
and i feel like i'm not like generally
worried about this knight on g3 because
what's it gonna do
i like this move and it feels like my
king
is relatively safe there's nothing wrong
with it and i've take six and i have
oops takes and i have this square for
the night eventually
i wonder how the cakes are doing
now i have to level them and
probably do some other stuff oh wait my
night
yeah i guess we can check them just to
make sure
um wait let's go here
i have no time when where did all the
time go
it feels like bullet almost wait let me
help you
oh it's cold that's nice like my heart
um okay let me this doesn't look like a
nice position
i forgot some ideas
okay i think i have to go back
i still don't like my position
oh i just missed something
dang it
oh um this doesn't look good
uh what do i do
ah run oh no and i have no time
no pre moves alone ah
run wait what just happened
oh they lost some time
[Laughter]
i was just doing random moves um
i was like wait my time is not cereal
just yet
okay that was funny um
i also hung my queen
that was kind of the point with so
little time all right that was just a
really stupid game um
but it did feel like i have a decent
position
um
maybe rogue f2 was better
even here i think ideas of f4 and bring
this knight over
those could be interesting but i mean at
first e4 didn't make a lot of sense but
then i
saw this f6 and then i was like oh
wait i thought my knight was trapped i
can go here
what is wrong with me
i thought the knight was trapped for the
longest time and i can just go to g4
okay nevermind this was just very silly
of me
yep anyways um
i feel like we should just kind of um
get back to the cakes because that's you
know essentially why you're here right
can you start with um okay so they're
done with the roof
the cakes are done being in the
refrigerator so you can't come
just so because we're gonna kind of come
back to this
oh does that make sense so do i just say
it now
yeah cool the cakes are done
baking and chilling in the fridge and
now we're going to cut into them and see
if we can not break the structure
of the cakes and also chess i guess i
don't know i tried
um anyways oh
it seems like it has no problem coming
out which is good
um or at least you know that's what i
hope
no it seems to be fine
it seems like it's okay i wonder if i
can just like
flip it and then he'll be fine
maybe if i i would prefer this surface
better
this one might be a bit small i don't
know what i'm gonna do
now let's just use this i think if we go
like this
oh i think it came out nice
perfect okay now we gently peel this
off it's a little baked into the cake
but that's
fine
it's pretty good and then you know this
can be like a snack
later whatever is left in there all
right
so now comes the difficult part
do i level this or do i not
i'm not sure what i'm supposed to do
it's not that it's not that like thick i
thought it was going to be bigger
which i was you know kind of worried
about it but it's not that big so i
wonder if i should
if i should even like mess with it
i don't know maybe i shouldn't maybe i
shouldn't cut it
maybe i should just leave it as it is
and then start coding to it
but it makes no sense right if i if i do
that
because then it would just be all one
level
i have no clue what i'm gonna do um
stop saying that i love going into
things i'm not that evil
okay i i don't know what i'm supposed to
do it's more than i thought it would be
so um
okay
oh no no wait no i'm stupid
no wait no this is perfect i'm gonna
leave it as it is
and i'm gonna cut
into it and then
i'm gonna use the other cake and also
cut into it and then i'm gonna stack
them on top of one another
perfect eventually you know you come up
with a plan
if not then you cry for an hour and then
something will come up
in that session all right let's put this
somewhere where
we don't need it like right there and i
think i'm gonna
take this away and then maybe put it
like this
and i'm gonna move these pieces a little
bit
i was making the joke earlier for those
of you who were in chicago with me
uh you probably saw that most of my all
the pieces on my chest
were like this and then i had one random
pawn that looked like that
which is funny um anyway so
let's let's uh bring this here
and just wipe it a little bit
and then i might bring the other cake
out and
and then we can start coding to it i
think
and hopefully you'll be fine i don't
know
sorry for all the troubles
cool thanks um
maybe i should do the same thing that i
did just now
this one looks like it's gonna come off
easier
also i don't know if people do this at
home
but usually what i do
with like specifically you know those
like yellow cakes i'm not much of a
chocolate fan i know that
that's probably gonna piss off some
people but um
what i usually do for like this yellow
cakes i kind of let it
not burn necessarily but i kind of let
it like
get brown it's not just like
at the peak when it's cooked i don't
know if that makes sense
but yeah anyways
is it wheat cake is that a thing no it's
just chocolate
um i don't think i mean
is does that exist
i don't know never heard of it um yeah i
think it's
like uh german chocolate cake or
something um
uh just trade and replace
yeah that's kind of what i'm going to do
here the problem is that i need to do
some like
scientific measuring and uh engineering
and
all of the stuff that i don't know how
to do
so essentially what we're going to do
now
is that we're going to cut like
this more or less you know like an outer
it doesn't make sense and anyways i'm
just gonna cut like a little edge here
and i'm gonna do the same on this one
and we're going to trade spots
yes that makes sense the question is how
big do i do it
i feel like around here should be okay
and then i'm going to cut the same here
and then we do another one in the center
and uh yeah wing it what's the words
that could happen
yeah exactly so let's just kind of like
start cutting i don't want to cut too
close to the edges because i don't want
it to accidentally break
off and
now we just cut it up this way
i feel like it's a bad thing to say
based on my reputation but i am
generally very precise with a knife
i don't want to like stab it too hard
because i'm afraid that it will break
i could be saying that i am very precise
with a knife but i remember in december
somehow i made a cut on my finger
it was relatively deep uh trying to cut
a paper cut
like a plastic cup i don't know i don't
know what i was doing it was just a bad
idea but
i ended up cutting myself due to that
okay now we're going to do the same on
this side i think
and hopefully it will work out if not
then it sucks because i already started
coding
but anyway so
let's just do this
and
the question is how are we going to
trade places because you know that's
that's gonna be a bit difficult i would
say
okay so let me think how to do this
i feel like i need like a third
spot maybe
i can use this or something
now comes the thinking part which is
where i'm not good at so
anyways oh thanks for the sub nice to
see you tours
they have been here since day one since
i started streaming
thank you and anyone feel free to
subscribe so you can get more content
like this where i just do stupid stuff
you just come with me to my adventures
of
doing things and because it's me who's
doing them you probably
end up in like some really convoluted
plot or something
um i was telling uh ben beforehand he
would ask me what's your best story and
i said
uh bombing threat in moscow hotel while
i was playing irofload
you know you just end up in situations
like that when it comes to me
um so yeah
um yeah it's a chessboard cake so
yeah technically i am a master chef
because i am
i'm a master i'm a woman international
master i'm a fida master i'm a national
master
that makes me a chef master right master
chef
yeah technically it wouldn't be
inaccurate um
okay so now let's figure out how i'm
going to do this because
this is going to be rough
so i wonder if i could like somehow
maybe i can use this one
if it breaks then it breaks and i suck
at this
okay but
maybe there's a way i can get underneath
this
and now underneath this one too
i should be wearing gloves
if i i'm afraid to break it because i
did break it at home
i feel like it's gonna break i'm really
scared right now
god damn it okay i don't know how to do
this
maybe i should like put this here
and then put this one more here and then
kind of like
oh maybe i should cut it
just to make sure
what does it feel like it's not cut
okay that should be good why don't you
want to go up
go up
oh my god what is happening
oh my god this is working okay this is
working
i wish i had help for the other side
just to make sure that it doesn't break
uh brittany can you please help me out
yeah if there is a way that you can like
somehow get this part so i can remove
this
yeah oh maybe like
yeah or that one and then we put it here
okay
yeah just so that it doesn't break
oh it's not there we go oh my god
yay oh i know i should have done that i
got crumbs here
okay okay perfect
perfect okay good that's great
great great okay now we got to do it
with this one which is even harder
because i accidentally put the parchment
paper in a way that it's just like
sinked in okay um
yeah i feel like we could like slide it
to the side
or we could also like
yeah then we like put it here or
something
okay you can grab this one and then
oh this part's really coming apart right
here
that's not good
if it breaks apart it's also like not
terrible oh it broke
okay shoot wait no it's really breaking
apart
like me um yeah
well if it breaks apart then it just
breaks apart and like that's
that's it um
oh nope this one's breaking this one's
breaking right here
okay it's mostly broken so i think we
can just like
you know would you move the center piece
would that make sense um
was this the original plan i'm very
confused
yeah me too um yeah we can just remove
the
center part somehow i don't know what
the plane
is okay
i don't know what's happening where
would you like this to go
there oh
okay that's much easier that's much
better okay
well you know it's like in chess
sometimes you know
the position breaks open and you're not
ready for it and
uh now you gotta have a whole new plan
and calculate
and do some analysis you know some
re-evaluation of the position
consider some candidate moves and then
you know figure out what to do from then
on
um yeah that's that's just how
that's just how it is sometimes it made
no sense i was trying to sound smart
um but it makes no sense anyways
um yeah yeah i mean i can't talk about
chess i feel like that's something that
i can do
if i talk about baking and like
strategies i just uh
you know
would you imagine like this is one of
those videos that like uh gordon ramsay
reacts to would you mind
would you imagine that okay that would
be that would be um
catastrophe anyways so let's
i think i need to code this again which
is you know
interesting experience
let's do this
sorry gordon ramsay god i have failed
you
okay now i gotta do the same with this
one this one
this one looks weird than this one which
you know makes me a bit concerned
but you'll be fine
nothing to worry about right
there's a lot to worry about actually
okay nice cut
i gotta do the same thing again
perfect now maybe i can move this to
the side if you're willing to move it's
not willing to move
okay why don't you just like smoosh to
the side
okay perfect now we put this
in here i feel like this one i can kind
of do on my own or at least i hope i can
because it's not like too
big
it's not what i was expecting but
oh
oh my god that was perfect
that was perfect okay wait now i need to
not break it
oh my god that was so good also like i
feel like i
i should say i feel like i should say
that you know maybe the camera i can't
really pick this up but i have really
shaky hands i don't know if you can see
but you know it feels nice when i can do
things like this without
just you know
breaking something okay now i gotta do
the same with that one and i'm making a
mess
but it'll be fine oh maybe i should i
should have just thrown this one in
there
it would have been easier this is what i
meant when i said that it was like
surgery because
you know it's like yeah why did i put it
here i should have just put it over
there i'm so stupid
okay god damn it that was a bad plan
and i was praising myself i look dumb
i may need your help i don't know
if uh
yes that's perfect except for the fact
that it doesn't fit but besides that
it's perfect
oh my god okay great great great
yeah i can just put something um
you know to to uh
compensate you know yeah yeah that's
just how it will be
also since it's already broken i can
just push it forward
and if not then we eat the edges and
like you know and the cake looks smaller
this is how it is now i gotta put the
center part in here which is going to be
funny because look at this little space
and look at that guy
but i'll be fine it'll be fine
you know things get broken all the time
that's just how it is okay
so now
how do i do this in like the most
logical way
i don't know how to do that maybe i can
put like
frosting in here
would that be a good idea yeah let's try
that out
oh we got this one right here we got
this one here this one seems to be like
good
good okay cool okay let me just i need
to
do this um
just walk it into place i don't think i
can do that
[Music]
um
what happened to the cake don't worry
about it that's you know
you don't need to worry about it it's
all fine it's all
it's all great and uh it's pretty much
just like my performance at chicago open
you know very put together
and very good and completely not losing
at all
um
what is happening here
wait sorry i'm trying to get the
frosting out but i don't know what's
going on here
i don't know if i'm doing something
wrong
[Laughter]
i'm trying to i'm trying to you know get
it to calm down but it like doesn't want
to do that
here okay
yeah so many people can do this job
better than me
oh that's so smart yeah perfect that's
why you can do it and i can't
just great thank you okay now let's put
it into
this box right here where you know
sadness happens just cover it up with
frosting that's how
that's how you're supposed to do it why
is it so difficult to squeeze
okay i got scared i thought it popped at
the top okay
um maybe you know maybe it will look
fine maybe it'll be terrible
i don't really know it's just harder
than i thought it would be
i thought it was going to be easier um
also i've never used a piping bag before
i don't know if you can tell
you can probably tell you know but
that's fine
that's fine that's what you're here for
you're here to watch me struggle
i don't i don't think you you're here to
like watch me succeed or something
also my mom is probably very
disappointed at me from
if she's watching the stream right now
probably cheese and she's like a busy
woman that has a lot of things to do but
you know if she is watching she's
probably very disappointed at me right
now
um let me put some more here
in this corner you know what matters the
thing is that you know every time i bake
it may not end up being the most
beautiful thing but it will taste good
that's the one thing that i have
you know some reassuring song i mean i
can't really
go bad and like i said i'm a much better
you know
cook than baker but um
that's just a job that i got today so
some days i'm a professional chess
player some days i'm a baker
and streamer so yeah i feel like that's
a decent job you don't
need to you know you don't need to go
into details on it
so let's just put this back right here
and
i think i'm gonna just like real quickly
smooth it all out
and
good now this needs to go
if i can do it right and it won't break
maybe
i don't know if i'm doing this wrong it
feels like i am
i feel like it's sticking to a parchment
and that's probably not good
wait wait wait wait before we do that
the smart thing to do is
get this guy out of the way and then we
put this one right here which is a
it's a mess but it'll be
ah or i can
oh no no no no wait
i can just move the parchment right here
perfect because at the end
or should i put it on top no no it's
fine
sorry i'm just very confused so we're
really low on uh space so i'm going to
have to stop but
um just so i know when to start
recording again what's
no i think does it look is it kind of
like that or does it have like
that icing totally across the top
hopefully
it has one it has one why topping across
the truck
okay yeah all right
what we don't have
okay well we didn't get this one out of
the way but that's fine
i have no idea what's happening now with
the stream also no i can't eat all of
this
my grandma is watching oh no that's not
good
ah okay shoot
oh it feels like that part is breaking
oh it's working kinda
oh that corner oops
no i don't think that would work of
course yeah
uh okay it's kind of
ah it broke okay let's just
okay well that's just how it is that's
just how it is sometimes you know it
breaks again and then
it's like when you lose again in a game
or something
anyways that's just how it is so
i mean yeah it's fine no one will see it
it'll be covered up
so who cares now
i don't want to keep using my hands
let me just wash my hands
[Music]
cause i don't have like gloves or
anything
what are people seeing right now are
they seeing anything we're still alive
yeah oh you're still alive yeah it's
just the finished
product is the world's just halfway
presentation we're not gonna get all
this
which is fine oh okay that's fine so
that means i can
like talk and say whatever i want
cool i don't have anything to say i was
just wondering
um all right let's get this guy
here it'll fit
like me in this rest
[Music]
yay this is how it was supposed to go
all throughout
yeah but it didn't anyways
you know it's me who is it's me who's
here right
so you you do kind of expect like some
destructive
uh something
anyways shall we
i think we should like make like a
little coat
on top of this then we can kind of like
go into
into um
like the next part yeah it was
satisfying right it was satisfying that
part
so i think now we can take like some of
this frosting
and hopefully just like put it on top
if that's okay if it won't break if it
breaks and that's
that's terrible but you know maybe we
can like just
put it in the middle or something also i
don't think it fits for this cake
but um usually you know the way that i
like
to eat cakes the best is with um
uh like tres leches style cake so
usually if i'm making a cake at home and
i am going to be one of the people
enjoying them
um usually i add
yeah i blend like regular milk
evaporated milk and condensed milk
together
i put it in the blender and then
um i poke a lot of holes with like a
they're like a toothpick or like a fork
on the cake
and i put it on like a big bowl where it
has a lot of space
and then i don't pull the milk mixture
in there
and then i let it sit for like well you
can eat it right away but it's best when
you let it sit for like
a couple of hours and that's that's my
that's my favorite type of cake
um all right so let's just
really quickly try to cover everything
up
sorry if i'm more quiet on this part
it's like you know sometimes you
actually need to focus on what you're
doing because otherwise it will be
terrible
you know what's funny i don't think
we're good to use a cakestone
ah that's fine
i mean i'm i'll be very afraid to
transfer this to somewhere else
[Music]
but yeah so that's kind of how it is
right now
and in case you just got here which is
very surprising because i've been
streaming for a while in case you just
got here
we're doing kind of like a baking stream
and i know it looks really weird but
it'll be fine at the end of it i promise
actually that's a terrible promise to
make
but you know i can oh my god i made a
little
hole here oh no oh
it's fine
just sit in there and
what was i gonna say oh yeah that this
is really weird but it'll be fine at the
end
oh so i hope let's really quickly just
put a little bit on this side
and then we can move on to the other
part and i have some white frosting too
that i can put on top
okay i'm not doing a great job but like
who really is in life if you think about
it like who really is doing a good job
not many people so it's fine
it's all fine um also my hand has
frosting now i'm gonna just like
wash it or something oh that's good now
i had frosting before
at least not this one
all right
um hi morphinski yeah we got cake
that's good um
all right so now we're going to go on to
part two of this uh
bizarre plan i should have just
covered this spot better what is part
two put the top on
do you get what i'm saying yeah
now that's part two of this really bad
surgery
you imagine me as your surgeon
you get put into like a anesthesia you
know and you feel it
watching over you and then the doctor
comes into your room and it's me
how terrible would that be um
all right now we gotta do the other part
which is bringing this
on top of this and i don't know if there
is like a
maybe i shouldn't have used this one
because now i need to wash it
but now what we need to do is
do the other part of bringing
the other cake on top
and then we can decorate however we want
not however we want but like however you
know
my skills take me to right
i would say that it's decent from afar
right now
would you guys agree
um
don't kill the cake i'll do my best it's
already you know kind of dead
but ah it's fine okay
now needs the part of like bringing this
here i could also
feel like it would be a bad idea
if i just somehow
yeah probably flipping it until here
it's a bad idea
so i probably shouldn't do that okay now
we're on to part two of this
thing and i'm in the britney again
take it okay britney i may need you
again sorry
but this is like a hard process also
i never watched any videos on how to
make this which is probably a mistake
uh but we need to bring this to here now
okay
and that's gonna be that's gonna be
rough but
um especially because i don't know how
to get this one
like through that surface
i think maybe i can get a better angle
oh no okay sorry about that
maybe i can use this right here it just
has a cake on it
maybe i can use this to like get this
part up
oh my god oh no i got a spatula
oh my imagine when god bend two on this
machine
wait uh no i think it's gonna break okay
i think
maybe you like need to put it
this is all fine this is just you know
how it is sometimes
and uh right here yeah i think it'll be
good
hopefully i don't know oh no
that's it perfect
just gently let it go
oh my god no this is breaking right here
it's fine
it's fine
is it breaking i don't know it will
taste the same and also
it also looks the same it'll look the
same and taste the same
maybe i should have cut the edges
well you still cut it yeah i could
but i would say that this is going
pretty well now the only part is that
this one
this one is a mess so i think i'll just
try to gently you know get it
to here and then from then on we can
kind of like slowly figure out
what we're gonna do with it and you know
that's how it is sometimes it's what
i've been saying this
entire day that's how it is sometimes
but you know the
the idea is that you're putting effort
into what you're doing and uh
i feel like you can definitely see my
stress here so let's just you know
plop this there and now we use the
frosting again to
fix all of our mistakes because that's
that's you know
what you do you use frosting to fix your
mistakes
so let's try this again maybe i should
use the white one
i think it'll be interesting just to
change it up and
all right let's use this white one and
let's throw that in there and let's pop
this
out oh this one's runnier and
now let's just
oh this one's going so much smoother
that's nice
um all right let's
just pull up this there and pull up this
here
and i would say that for the most part
so like pretty good
besides that so let's just pull up that
there
and yeah should be fine now
it's all good oops okay
let's put this here now and
i'm so happy that like we're almost done
we're not really
done but you know this is better than i
expected i thought it was going to fall
apart
on the entirely you know i thought that
it was just going to be a lot worse than
how it actually was
so let's just do that and now we plot
the center
i'm so nervous okay
yeah i would say i'm doing decent uh it
could be like a lot better but it could
also be
like a lot of oars so now we pull up
this in the middle
and then it has like some frosting on it
anyways we plop that in the middle and
let me go get this
white thing again and now we put the
frosting into the places where it
uh maybe doesn't fit and that's fine you
know
like i said you can cover up your
mistakes with frosting and no one will
know
especially if i use like the fondant now
which i don't
know i've never ventured into that
i feel like i feel like the model of the
story is
uh just spike cake
just buy it yeah anyways so
yeah this is all looking pretty nice i
would say
yeah maybe i should put a little bit
more frosting to
fix that more even and
that feels better
cool also my feet hurt i shouldn't have
been
wearing heels today um
anyways this looks great
uh okay perfect
we got most of this part done now i
wonder if i should just put frosting all
across
it and then like maybe try and cut up
some fondant for it
i wonder if that's a good idea in fact i
think i'm gonna do that
i think i'm gonna do that so let's you
know
let's start you know maybe piping
all across the top and then see
how we do and if it sucks then it sucks
i mean
what can you do
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was unexpected um okay cool cool
cool
anyways um do you guys have any chest
questions for me
i thought that i would like answer a few
we can leave it at that for now
yep then i can come back to it later
and get some more
ah
no i am not adding what kind of sugar
especially because
i can't consume it then
[Music]
okay it looks decent
it doesn't look too bad like it could be
a lot worse
i feel like
i should probably add more now i never
realized how much frosting goes into
cake
maybe it's just me for not knowing how
to do it but
i never thought about it
i wish the levels were more even it just
looks like a really weird dome
right now
okay let me get the thing back
stop doing that
okay let's hope that we can like
make this a little bit even and we can
put this through here we can get this to
this
corner never forget the corners
night on the rim look stem did you guys
ever hear that
i didn't growing up but i heard it
recently
anyways let's just kind of like pretend
that we know what we're doing
and put this all across the top
i don't know if i should put it on the
sides i have the feeling that i should
probably cut the sides
but i don't know how i don't know how
good of an idea that actually
is maybe i should just so that it's a
little bit even
maybe i should do that
i hope it doesn't break when i do that
maybe i can use one of this knives to do
that
and just like chop chop and it'll be
good
right
oh no i have a feeling that it won't be
good maybe i just got like the bottom
one a little bit
there we go because i feel like if i cut
the top one it's just going to be like
um it's just going to be like
uh it's going to fall apart i feel like
so let's just
okay that feels nice so i can taste the
cake now
how much elo has a cake
um by the looks of it i would say maybe
like
1300
so that's good
okay i've also made a mess
so that's that's not great
okay now we gotta put frosting on the
sides
and i feel like in general like i see so
many people who
like have like a i would say like a four
digit rating
and then they say no or i asked them
right
like when did you start playing and they
have a nice rating like
i would say 1500 plus
and then they're like oh i started over
quarantine and it's like wow how did you
get so good so quickly i feel like i see
so many of those people nowadays
uh i feel like we're almost done with
this part
and that's decent and then we go to this
side and then we smoosh it all out
and now we do this side
i don't know if this is how i remember
but i was like a very soccer player the
first couple of years that i
that i was into chess i mean i didn't
have good results but it also feels like
i was
kind of a bad player
maybe it's just because i didn't have an
actual rating so just
you know i wasn't so sure about it but
overall you know kind of feels like i
wasn't that good when i was younger
then you know with time i eventually
kind of
tried to understand more my play and
stuff
although i still have no like definitive
idea of how i play because it feels like
my
i can't see this part
how did chocolate get there what
but i feel like um it's hard to even
like for me understand my chest style so
seeing people like
some of them are like 2 000 and
seeing them you know do so well
if they started playing so recently
although i guess yeah 2000
online is not the same as 2000 over the
board but i've seen them do so well from
so recent it's
you know very impressive
all right i think it's good for the most
part i can't really see
from this side but i think it's kind of
all right and now
i think i may just try and put fondant
on top of it but i think before that i
need to clean
up the surfaces a little bit so
let's just eat some of this cake
okay now i need to clean this up let me
put this away somewhere
and what else should i do i should throw
this out
and i should get this night out of the
way
yeah let's get this out of the way too
and
maybe we should get this out of the way
too
and if i need again i'll wash it if not
then i'll also wash it
but okay let's try and clean up this a
little bit
um
okay um i don't think so but i also felt
bad throwing it away
maybe
i don't know um okay let me just
get like a paper towel and then
clean up this guy
i don't like to cook well everything is
messy
same way that i don't like to eat while
everything is messy
because i kind of take it as like a
relaxing thing
and i hate it when it's all messy
i'm by no means an organized person i'm
really not but
you know i also don't like to see the
mess
um am i going to eat a chess piece i
feel like i've done that today right i
had a pretty good score against you guys
so i would say that that's quite decent
especially with two queens i took two
queens uh during my games
i feel like that's very that's very
impressive you know
in the first two games um
yeah it was a piece of cake exactly um
did i call the knife at night i don't
think so also i didn't realize you were
here otherwise
i would have given a shout out uh
okay there we go
damn it i'm not logged in can you please
do it
uh into twitch can you please give a
shout out to
ray robertson oh yeah
um i streamed once in eight days
yeah you i mean like you stream when i
don't stream and that's
that's that's crazy i guess it's good
though because that way i get to watch
and i try to watch the other day but
it's like the second time
that you stream and i am packing
to go back home from a tournament so it
doesn't really time well
but yeah it's fine i try
um ayan he was streaming with the phone
too
and uh yeah is it someone's birthday
probably but i don't know who
i mean it must be someone's birthday
today in this world right
oh my god okay what do i do now
okay do we want the cake to be generally
white or
black i feel like
both of them are fine i probably should
go with black because white is just
gonna
get like so messy with the color so i'm
gonna try the black one
and i'm gonna get my hands
so colored that's dense
that's so funny am i supposed to roll
with this oh sorry i'm gonna get tango
what
okay i don't know what that means but
um
uh shouting out imagine a shout out
oh my god
if not then this idea will get scrapped
because i'm really
struggling although i would i wouldn't
particularly call myself a weak person
okay oh my god
why is it so difficult
i don't want you to see me struggle in
the stream it was all supposed to go
smooth and nice
um god damn it
why is this so difficult
isn't there like a can there be like
some
alcohol bottle here from someone that
you know was like
here earlier and i can just use it as a
rolling pin
instead of this
is it is it illegal to show that on
stream um
there must be i mean
right
actually you checked
he checked okay okay okay oh my god why
is this so difficult
yeah position is slightly under pressure
yeah
i can't believe how i'm supposed to roll
this all the way so that i can cover all
of that
also why are these things here this just
looks silly
okay okay
if not then i won't do this and i'll
just like
i don't know cry or something but
dang it this is hard
but we're getting there kind of imagine
that it now just like sticks to the
bottom
and then i have to suffer oh you know
what i should do i should probably get
this out of the way
and then wow i'm so smart
okay perfect no that was a terrible idea
that wasn't very smart
just cooperate why don't you just cover
it
perfect okay why can't you be
like this from the beginning
um
yeah i need a bigger rolling pin for
spreading but also for hitting someone
this is a little
uncomfortable but you know maybe we'll
get there at some point
it's like you know like a technical win
in the game
and then you don't win for like the next
40 moves
really there's no like something that i
can use instead of this
maybe i can use like the bottom of a pan
and
it will like grow bigger or something
do you think i can just like
doesn't quite work
i don't know i don't know what happens
if you warm up fondant
anyways how are you guys doing today
okay well i don't think that did
anything i think
just take back that idea unfortunately
i don't think it helped i'm not going to
smash it with my hand i just feel strong
so also don't look at my nails too much
they're not that great
oh my god why is this so difficult
could there could there be like maybe
like some rolling down here or something
it's fine we'll get there
we'll get there at some point hopefully
wait will it stick to the bottom okay no
it doesn't okay that's good
i was worried there for a second
okay it's kind of somewhat working but
it also has like this weird lines that i
don't like
maybe i should take this off oops
is this the same louis chess club
kitchen no this is a warehouse that they
kidnapped me too
and now i'm like somewhere in kansas
city
yes that's right
definitely not in the gm house
is this marzipan phone then i don't
really know
i have no clue ah
this is difficult
but we're kind of like almost getting
there it's not the best
but best is not always
best
but i mean it's much better than at the
beginning right maybe i just have to do
this for a while but
you know it's much better than how i was
at first
right
in a slice in a scale of one to ten how
good is this cake
i would say like maybe um
well i made it so it's obviously a ten
yeah that's that's what i should say
damn it just wrong why don't you
why is this difficult
someone is coming here
it's kind of working i would say
there's someone here
i don't know what's happening but
there's someone here i'm very
embarrassed
right now
oh okay cool
okay i feel like this is still not
enough
for like the whole cake so maybe i need
to roll it more
don't look at me i'm already struggling
enough
don't look at me
[Laughter]
that's because you're from afar yeah
also look at this
[Laughter]
i've been struggling here for so long is
that even a real rolling pin that's like
the worst thing
oh rook and roll that's a good one yeah
rook and roll that's
that's nice as you can see i also have
like this cutouts maybe i can just do
that too
oh my god why is this taking so long
it's funny because i'm a chess player
but i'm also a very like
desperate person i don't like waiting
the only waiting that i can do is doing
a chess game
but like in general
i don't like waiting that much
or like doing things that take a long
time
this is really a workout you know so
like if you want to
ever like bake consider it
a workout and then you get a treat at
the end which is nice
how long have i been doing this for do
you know three hours
three hours what
oh my god
this is so difficult
yeah tomorrow my arms will be like more
sore than
what they were after i got my two
coveted shots
so that's great of course
it's kind of getting there though i
still don't think it's right
but it's kind of
getting there
is this like good enough i don't think
it's good enough for everything
maybe i can like
i think it's too thick
maybe i kind of like flip it and then
keep working with it oh that's better
i feel like we're getting there kind of
thank goodness this was in a bigger cake
otherwise you know
it would be lots of struggle
i feel like you guys are getting like so
many memes today
for content
also i love how professional this is
going to be for the
chess hall of fame
oh okay i don't know if this is good
enough like big enough for it
i'm not sure i also don't know if i want
to keep doing this
we can try we can try okay
ah maybe it's good
kinda
welp a little bit
would say that it's a little bit like oh
no i touched it
dang it oh no i keep doing that
i would say that for the most part it's
like quite decent
i don't need to worry about this that
much because like
um i'm gonna like keep putting some more
fondant stuff on top of it
but like oh it's this to press it
maybe this is a stupid idea but i i mean
i'm gonna have fun with it let's pretend
that
this is doing something i just think
it's funny
it's probably not doing anything but
okay wait wait okay now we transfer this
to this
so i can see it better and
maybe this is for like the sides too oh
this feels nice it feels right i don't
know if this is what you're meant to use
it for
but it does feel right um so
yeah oh i struggled for so long
and it doesn't even look that great
which is a funny part but you know
it's fine now let's cut this here on the
sides
let's cut the excess
now what do you do with this fondant i
don't know
then you got the edges here
i should press this one better
oh but it already has cute frosting on
it
let me just clean this up
and then you like
press it i'm sure that's what you're
meant to do right
i have no clue okay now we take away
these parts that are not
going to be used
that's a thing of a chess player right
done you know you gotta figure out the
problem
and you gotta you gotta um
uh you know come up with solutions you
know
to the problems yeah
oh my god this has been so difficult
okay now i'm gonna coat some edges on
the other side
okay perfect
and now let's cut off this side too
and this part right here is the only one
that is a little bit messed up
that's okay
i can actually like maybe use this part
to cover this part up
perfect no one will notice no one will
see
okay i feel like i gotta wash my hands i
have way too much chocolate i'm frosting
in my hands
you know what's the funny part and now i
gotta do the same with the white
frosting thingy
oh okay now maybe time oh i almost just
tangled myself
um now it may be time to like move this
away perhaps
it doesn't look that great it's like all
right at best
but you know why don't we all like that
let's leave this here and
yeah i can't believe it's been three
hours either um
my voice sounds different in the kitchen
was it what does that mean i thought it
would sound the same
maybe it sounds different when i speak
english in spanish that's something that
i have you know
heard before but
when i'm playing chess and when i'm
cooking i never heard that my voice is
different
it also depends on the day some days i
sound happier some days i don't
just kind of depends on the day all
right
let's just i am more relaxed okay i'll
take that as a compliment
um okay now we're gonna use this other
fondant with like
oops sorry like the little silly rolling
pin
but i'm not going to struggle this much
on it i think i'm just going to like
what should i do should i cut like
little squares and try to make a
chessboard
maybe oh this is hard
or i also have like these things which
are like maybe way too big
but i can just like blob pieces you know
i can also do that do you guys have any
recommendations of what you want to see
oh
oh why is this so hard
my mic went off oh
did it go off or no
it shouldn't be off what
wait what is happening there's no
problem
oh are you guys just strolling with me
okay audio is good thank you
thank you for letting me know
dang it
i don't know if i quite like this
rolling pin
anyways what do you guys think should i
like cut
like those big chess pieces oh
oh you want to use a cookie okay we can
use those
i think they're a little too big from
for this
but um you know we can we can still
shape out some stuff
oh this is hard
i'm gonna be so ripped by the end of
this
the microwave idea is good really
i feel like i should burn something if i
put it in the microwave like this
also it feels like i'm like close to
getting there so
maybe maybe i'm not but i like to think
i am
actually i'm very far from it the other
thing i was going to do is i was going
to
like maybe cut a bunch of white squares
to put on the cake and then we do like a
little
board at the top
oh maybe i can do that in like some
spots okay that's
interesting i just had an idea
okay
this is so difficult
i am a weird looking chess stream
oh no this is a weird looking chest
stream i was like what
yeah this is a weird looking chest
stream but you know
that's how it is sometimes we got a
little bit of the
i've gotten a little bit of cake on it
it's fine worst case scenario you know
we just like
don't look at the exterior it's like you
know it's like with people you don't
look at the
exterior just you know
try to understand if they're nice and
sweet and if they're
good for you and
don't look at the outside of the cake
too much
what matters is the inside yeah
i just i feel like that's an excuse for
the cake looking like crap
okay let me just
keep doing this for a little bit
and then maybe we'll get somewhere
but i don't know
ah this looks so hard
what am i preparing this is supposed to
be
um this is supposed to be a chess cake
oh you're right this is like a squeeze
for the games would it be called a user
i'm still not sure what the meaning of
that word is
oh yeah this is pretty much like in a
game when you're doing the squeeze
you're trying to beat your opponent
senseless
to the point where he wants to cry
actually i feel like that got a little
out of hand
oh i kind of don't want to do this
anymore
this is way too difficult
holding the roller under hot water
maybe that's one idea
let's try that let's try that
i don't know why the water isn't hot
here which is weird
um so i don't think i can do that
unfortunately
but it's weird the water doesn't come
out hot here
that's strange
um okay
i am doing constant progress so that's
good
that's the one good thing
also i feel like we're close to like
start shaping some stuff
if i come into it now it's like too
thick or something
maybe i should flip it so that
like it becomes easier because the other
side
i don't know it's different oh my god
why is it this color
what just happened why is it like this
oh my god that's weird i don't
understand why it's this color
is it okay yeah you think so
i don't know
maybe oh maybe we got some of the black
one because we'll put one on top of the
other
okay that's fine if it's not then it's
okay i thought it was something worse
yeah i think we're like almost ready to
start cutting stuff
okay maybe we should try
let's try conning some shapes into this
okay
and see how that goes i wish i
had something to lift it up with
let me just get this real quick
okay i would say that this skin looks
nice
uh maybe i should
there we go
sir would you please like to oh my god
that's perfect
shall we put it somewhere like here
it's looking good what
okay we're getting there we're getting
there
okay
thank you yes i'm very patient i i don't
understand why or how
but you know it seems seems like it's
kind of working
also i think i'm gonna
um like cut
a few
squares here
see how that goes i feel like i almost
got my finger just now
okay perfect now i need to get this guy
far away from the rest
great you flip over
to this side and you flip
this and this one is a little too thick
actually
i need to roll it out a little bit
but essentially what i want to do
i feel like a knife would be better
sorry like i said i think i'm more
precise with knives
which probably makes me look really bad
i would say that this is like about how
i want it maybe like
this is better perfect now i'm gonna
cut down the middle
okay let's try
how about we put it like
here perhaps and then this one
here
does that look bad
thank you oh
it looks kind of cute actually
i mean it's starting to get shape i
think
oh okay okay okay
and maybe now i can do i don't like how
it has selected
it just not clean out but
what to do what to do okay now let's do
i believe this is supposed to be a queen
right over here
yeah yeah maybe we can like make
no it's a little weird
do you think that's accurate
i feel like it's going to this side
i don't want to break it either
okay
you guys think it looks good thank you i
mean i wasn't expecting
that i feel like it could be
a lot better but for someone that has
like a
maybe 1 000 rating at baking
maybe it's okay
maybe
oh where should i put it
maybe just there i don't know what else
i should do
i have no idea is that it
i don't know what do you think
what's it
what do you think i mean it's funny i'm
really tired
okay you think so i don't like it
you don't like it look how cute
what do you think i think really
yeah do you want to give a conclusion
um should we like open it
yeah say like and here's my cake
and i'm gonna get turned out let's cut
and do it yeah
oh they're saying don't overdo it
okay i agree it's good how it is
[Music]
all right so i'm rolling again so we
gotta we gotta wrap it up
okay cool so let me just clean this up a
little bit so that
it doesn't look so bad on the sides um
yeah do you need this little uh utensil
oh no
um gosh i hate it anyways
really i don't know um
let me just maybe i can
clean the sides i don't think i can like
move the whole cake
but
oh yeah i was gonna clean up the sides
before you do that but um
like try to make it less
more professional i guess i should say
like i said what matters is the inside
right
yeah also like this is my first time
decorating a cake i've never done that
before
so i'm not like i'm not like too
too mad at it maybe i can
uh wait let me see if this side
oh this side is so wonderful a little
messed up
i wish i had the little
thingy that you press with i can just
throw it here
i don't know if i should add like
anything else
okay thank you
oh you guys are saying that it looks
really good thank you that's so nice
also my feet really hurt because i've
been wearing heels for so long
but um yeah i guess this is kind of
it i don't know if there is a good angle
for it
um i'm trying to look for one but i
don't see it
anyways um
you want to take a photo yeah okay go
ahead okay
how about you like hold it toward me hey
mine and i drop it
like like this yeah yeah and then like
oh yeah we should probably cut into it
to see if it works
um well here's the thing do we want to
save this for the hall of fame
production because we can only cut into
it once
yeah we want to save it for that all
right so we can sign off the stream now
oh okay so you guys won't see it being
caught open but it will be
apparently and
wait you're saying i bought it did you
just like
log in here and you do not see like my
last three hours of work
um but if you if you are insinuating
that someone
you know would sell this and i paid for
it
i guess that's a good thing um anyway so
yeah i hope you guys had
fun today um it was really fun
and yeah we'll cut into a little a later
time and also
i believe uh it's gonna be posted
um in july july in july with the
world chess hall of fame so
yeah if you can is there a way to check
out like the exhibitions from online
yeah there's going to be all kinds of
content um
there's an exhibition page on the
website right now and then there will be
like virtual tours and things
so yeah in your video i guess my video
the
virtual tours and also you can come in
here and check out the
uh check please exhibition
yeah and then you know if you're in town
go to keenside diner it's pretty cool
also chess is going to get interesting
this upcoming months
with the um in august they have the
um the stingfield cup and the rabbit and
blitz and all of that stuff and also now
in july
they have the juniors and i believe the
seniors too i'm not entirely sure
but um yeah so it's like you know i
would say that summer it's kind of like
the best time to
to come here and maybe like enjoy the
vibe of the central west sand and the
saint louis and all of this area so yeah
i hope you guys enjoyed the stream go
follow my channel i have my own channel
italia26 go follow it if you can
and join my discord because i'm very
active there and i usually announce when
i'm streaming
and i guess that's about it
so yeah thank you so much for being here
it will be the world championship cake i
don't that's too much
but yeah it was fun being here so yeah
um i'll see you guys oh caleb is here
congrats to caleb for winning his
section in the
in the chicago open yeah
and i'll see you guys soon
all the time
do